[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer im
Moment scheint es als seit Putins Regime
unantastbar und unzerstörbar Russlands
Wirtschaft hält in Sanktionen besser
stand als viele erwartet hatten auch
wenn sich mit Beginn des Jahres 2023 der
Wind schon deutlich gedreht hat außerdem
jegliche Opposition im Lande ist
unterdrückt Proteste und Demos in
schlichtweg verboten kritische Medien
ins Exil gedrängt und selbst wer als
Privatperson einfach nur ein paar
ehrliche Worte über putinskrieg in der
Ukraine äußerst kann im Gefängnis landen
Putin hat es also geschafft
scheibchenweise ein totalitäres System
zu etablieren indem er die Freiheiten
der Menschen nach Belieben ein und
ausschalten kann und auch mit vielen
Funktionsträgern in den inneren
grammelkreisen die Ausweglosigkeit von
Putin Ukraine Abenteuer und Russland
faktische internationale Isolierung sehr
schmerzhaft bewusst sein dürfte eine er
wollte gegen den Diktator Deutschland
akut nicht bevorzugen wenn ihr wollt
könnten wir sie auch putschpalast
Revolution oder auf Standard aber reale
Video Anzeichen dafür sind vorerst nicht
zu entdecken Putin scheint auch im
großen oder in kleinen in der Tat alle
Fäden in der Hand und alle Akteure in
der Tasche zu haben selbst wenn wir
offiziell unbestätigten Berichten
glauben schenken dass Putin schwer krank
sei an Krebs oder parkinsonleiter und
deshalb immer mehr anstrengender Termine
an einen putzmunteren Doppelgänger
delegieren müsste es bleibt der Fakt das
System Putin hat Russland eiserne im
Griff
denn auch wenn Putin persönlich eines
Tages nicht mehr über Russland herrschen
kann was unweigerlicher irgendwann
passieren wird müssten eigentlich all
seine Spießgesellen Wasserträger und
korrupten Kumpels das existenzielle
Interesse haben dass dieses System
erhalten bleibt schließlich handelt es
sich um ein System das Ihnen über viele
Jahre ein Stück von der Macht und reiche
Pfunde geboten hat und Gott behüte ist
käme ja heraus mit welchen
Machenschaften sie sich das alles
verschafft haben aber halt könnte es
nicht sein dass wir an dieser Stelle
einer strafrechtlich kremlzentrischen
Sichtweise aufgesessen sind könnte es
nicht sein dass das eigentliche Problem
für Russland Zukunft und sein
Fortbestehen als Staat nicht
irgendwelche Hinterzimmer Entriegelung
im Gremmel sind sondern kaum steuerbare
dynamische Prozesse die weit ab von
Moskau vor sich gehen und nein ich meine
jetzt nicht die ukrainische Armee die an
der russischen Südwestgrenze offenbar
schon die Panzermotoren warenlaufen
lässt und auf das Signal für gegen
Offensive wartet sollte dieser allgemein
erwartete militärische Gegenschlag
richtig Erfolg haben dürfte dies
natürlich Russland militärisiertes
Herrschaftssystem in einem gewaltige
Sinn und marktkrise stürzen könnte es
nicht sein dass sich just im Moment
eines militärischen Fiaskos oder
vielleicht auch erst etwas später dann
ganz andere Randregionen und Provinzen
des Landes von Mütterchen Russland
lossagen kurz um könnte Putins Imperium
namens Russische Föderation einfach so
zerfallen und zwar so wie es 1991 schon
ihr Vorgänger vorgemacht hat die ach so
rumreiches so wird Union das kam damals
nämlich auch ziemlich überraschend und
dauert im Großen und Ganzen nur ein paar
Monate wäre eine Wiederholung dieser
Prozesse heute wirklich möglich ja und
was würde danach passieren nun es mag
euch vielleicht überraschen aber der
Zerfall Russland gehört zu Putins
größten Sorgen und ängstensten
mit anderen Worten eine mögliche
Balkanisierung Russland also eine von
Konflikten angetriebene Verspätung in
mehrere Territorium Einzelstaaten ist
nicht etwas was wir hier auf
visualpolitik erfunden haben es ist kein
Wunschdenken dass wir um jeden bisher
beirreden wollen es handelt sich um eine
tief verwurzelte Furcht die Putin selbst
umtreibt und in der Tat gibt es gute
Gründe zur Annahme das Russland eines
Tages tatsächlich auseinanderbrechen
könnte möglicherweise ist dieser Tag
sogar näher als wir es uns heute
ausmalen können prinzipiell müssen wir
im Hinterkopf behalten dass Russland ein
klassischer viel völkerstaat ist ein
Land aus Dutzenden Lokal einheimischer
Ethnien von denen viele ganz anders
gestrickt sind als die Russen die mit
über 70% der Bevölkerung trotz absolut
kaputter Demografie noch immer die
unbestritten größte Volksgruppe im Lande
darstellen zugleich sprechen wir aber
auch über eine sehr dünn besiedeltes
Staatswesen von enormer Ausdehnung das
von der Ostsee bis zum Pazifik reicht
und vom praktischen Ozean bis ans
Schwarze Meer außerdem die Gefahr eines
Zerfalls oder zumindest eine aushöhung
der Russischen Föderation war vor gar
nicht mal so lange Zeit schon einmal ein
akutes Problem
ihr alle kennt sicher grob die
Hintergründe der beiden Kriege und in
unserem vorletzten Video haben wir auch
schon über die gefahrene salafistischen
Jihad für die Integrität Russlands
gesprochen heute werden wir uns
anschauen welche weiteren
Zentrifugalkräfte darüber hinaus die
Russische Föderation auseinanderreißen
könnten und dabei jenem Beispiele genau
unter die Lupe nehmen die Würfe
besonders kritisch halten fangen wir
hierzu mit einer Region an über die
nicht so häufig in den News berichtet
wird die dafür aber umso mehr
Aufmerksamkeit verdient hätte tataster
denn wusstet ihr dass die Republik hat
das tan also diese Region mitten in
Russland die ihr hier auf der Karte
sieht eigentlich kurz nach Vorstand ein
unabhängige und souveräner Staat zu
werden und dazu müssen wir nicht mal
sehr weit in der Zeit zurückgehen wir
sprechen hier von
1992 aber zunächst einmal ein paar hatte
Fakten Russland besteht heute
Verwaltungs technisch aus 83
verschiedenen territorialen Einheiten wo
man dann in Moskau der Meinung ist es
sein inzwischen 89 denn sechs weitere
Verwaltungsgebiete stellen die 2014
Ostukraine auch wenn diesen nicht einmal
gänzlich kontrollieren im Prinzip sind
diese vielen Territorien in ihrem
Rechtsstatus innerhalb der Russischen
Föderation gleichberechtigt auch wenn es
bei den amtlichen Namen dieser
föderationsobjekte traditionell ein
ziemlich buntes
21 Republiken 46 Gebieten nun Regionen
vier autonome Kreise dazu noch zwei
Städte mit föderalm Status und als ob
das noch nicht genug wäre ein autonomes
Gebiet klar all diese Begriffe sind
etwas verwirrend aber das kommt ja auch
in anderen Ländern vor in Deutschland
nennt sich ja auch drei Bundesländer aus
einer Laune heraus Freistaaten und zwei
sind freie Hansestädte Berlin darf im
Amts Deutsch auch nicht als Stadt
bezeichnet werden sondern als Land aber
das nur nebenbei bemerkt zurück nach
Russland viel wichtiger als die
Betätigung sind die ökonomischen
Unterschiede zwischen diesen Regionen
diese sind mitunter wahrlich extrem noch
viel ungleicher als in der Europäischen
Union mit ihrem enormen
Einkommensgefälle zwischen reichen und
armen Mitgliedstaaten
[Musik]
in Russland kann also das pro Kopf BIP
der reichsten Region des Landes wenn der
Ölpreis gut steht bis zu 60 Mal höher
liegenden als dass der ärmsten Gebiete
in der EU beträgt diese Spannweite nur
das 16-fache exorbitant sind auch der
regionalen Unterschiede bei der
Bevölkerungsstärke die Stadt muss kaum
mit ihren 13 Millionen Bürgern hat 300
mal mehr Einwohner als der autonome
Jensen Kreis in dieser
nordosteuropäischen tot 3 Region leben
mit 41 000 Menschen so viele wie z.B in
der netten Stadt Schwäbisch Hall aber
auf einer Fläche die so groß ist wie
halb Deutschland apropos
Bevölkerungsdichte während sie über
5.000 muskelbieter auf einem
Quadratkilometer drängen haben die
Bewohner von schokotka das ist das
Gebiet ganz hinten an der Behringstraße
sage und schreibe pro Kopf 15
Quadratkilometer für jeden Menschen und
natürlich auch vergessen Rentiere ihr
seht schon die strukturellen
Unterschiede der Regionen Ausland sind
gewaltig und man könnte dann natürlich
sagen warum sollten eigentlich Gebiete
die so extrem weit voneinander entfernt
und so diametral unterschiedlich sind
überhaupt in einem Staat Zusammenleben
hätten wir alle und die Menschen dort
vielleicht auch es nicht viel leichter
wenn Russland in tausend Stücke zerfiele
nun nicht zuvor schnell interne Risse in
Russland könnten eine globale Krise von
gigantischem Ausmaß auslösen dazu nur
ein einziger abschreckender Gedanke wer
würde denn in so einem Fall Russlands
riesiges Atomwaffenarsenal kontrollieren
vielleicht ein Freistaat groß Moskau im
Zentrum Russlands tja netter Gedanke
aber Russlands interkontinental Raketen
sind vorrangig auf Atom U-Booten
untergebracht und die sind nun mal nicht
direkt vor den krempelmauern auf der
Mosbach stationiert sondern 1500 km
weiter nördlich bei uns sowie bei der
Pazifikflotte 7000 km weiter östlich auf
Kamtschatka im Falle des Szenarios einer
total Zersplitterung würde da locker ein
halbes Dutzend neuer starten dazwischen
liegen ihr seht schon dieses Zapf als
Szenario ist sehr heikel und auch wenn
es momentan als noch nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich scheint wir sollten
zumindest ansatzweise darauf vorbereitet
sein und es durchdenken deshalb stellen
wir uns heute ein paar provokante Fragen
und klopfen Sie man ganz nüchtern ab was
hält Russland eigentlich im Inneren
zusammen könnte sich Putins Riesenreich
wirklich territorial auflösen welche
Gebiete könnten sich abspalten und warum
sollten sie das überhaupt wollen und
könnten dabei auch Nachbarstaaten die
Finger im Spiel haben heute werden wir
all diese Fragen natürlich beantworten
und zwar gleich nach einem wichtigen
Hinweis des Sponsors der das heutige
Video möglich gemacht hat es geht dabei
nämlich um ein ziemlich ernstes Thema
Datenmissbrauch durch sogenannte data
Broker also datenmakler diese greifen
unsere persönlichen Daten überall im
Netz ab und verkaufen sie danach nicht
nur als seriöse Unternehmen sondern auch
alle Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns dann mit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
uns sogar auszunehmen leider haben wir
keine Kontrolle darüber an wen die data
Broker unsere Daten verkaufen aber sie
sind gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet unsere
Daten zu löschen wenn wir sie dazu
auffordern das Problem dabei es gibt
Tausende von ihnen oft ist der
Antragsprozess absichtlich kompliziert
gestaltet deswegen resignieren viele
Menschen und lassen den ganzen Schwung
einfach einfach über sich ergehen aber
jetzt kommt die gute Nachricht der
Sponsor dieses Videos inkognit bietet
genau dafür eine Lösung an inkognit
übernimmt die Aufgabe bei den data
Brokern aufzuräumen die Löschanträge zu
stellen und und so vor Betrugsversuchen
zu schützen du meldest dich einfach bei
inkognit anbeauftragst die in deinem
Namen die Löschanträge durchzusetzen und
verfolgst dann bequem auf einem
übersichtlichen Dashboard wie deine
Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es für einen normalen Menschen
nahezu unmöglich diese ganzen
Löschanträge selbst zu bearbeiten und
sich vor Betrug zu schützen also du was
gutes für deine datenhygien und schau
dir in kognügen über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung an außerdem mit dem
Promo Code politik.de erhältst du auch
noch sage und schreibe 60% Rabat wenn du
so den ersten 100 gehörst die ihn nutzen
und falls Du uns etwas Nettes tun willst
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung oder
diesem Video findest du einen Spenden
Link mit dem du unsere Arbeit auch
freiwilliger Basis direkt unterstützen
kannst wir danken euch an dieser Stelle
schon mal für eure Hilfe so und nun
lasst uns wieder zur Beantwortung
unserer wichtigen Fragen schreiben was
hält Russland eigentlich im Internet
zusammen könnte sich Putin Riesenreich
wirklich territorial auflösen welche
Gebiete könnten sich abspalten und warum
sollten sie das wollen und könnten dabei
auch Nachbarstaaten die Finger im Spiel
haben um diese Fragen zu beantworten
werden wieso oft erstmal einen
lehrreichen Blick in die Geschichte die
wirklich vieles erklärt
russlandsgrenzen eine wabernde Masse
[Musik]
der Russlands Geschichte studiert
erkennt schnell dass es drei eiserne
Regeln gibt die seit Jahrhunderten
gelten die erste ist das Russland
permanent dazu neigt zu expandieren ein
paar jahrhundertelang war diese
Expansion vorrangig nach Osten und
Südosten gerichtet und viel in Europa
gar nicht besonders auf während die
Mächte der alten Welt sich nach und nach
kolonialreichen Übersee zusammenhaften
Verein hatte das russische Reich das nur
sehr dünn besiedelte Sibirien und später
auch Mittelasien irgendwann kam es aber
auch in diesen Richtungen mit den
herrschaftsbereichen anderer großer
Mächte ins Gehege sicher viele andere
Länder haben auch territoriale
Streitigkeiten mit Nachbarn aber der
Fall Russlands ist schon eine ganz
besondere Kategorie für sich
[Musik]
ein Beispiel das sind die Bilder aus der
Republik Tuba sie hat eine Fläche so
groß wie die drei baltischen Staaten
zusammengenommen liegt an der Grenze zur
Mongolei die meiste Zeit an der
Geschichte wurde dieses Gebiet von China
kontrolliert doch ab 1912 kriegt es
unter russischen Einfluss anfangs noch
des Zarenreichs dann der Sowjetunion die
Phase der zumindest formellen
Unabhängigkeit des bitte armens Sowjet
satellitenstraße endete 1944 sang und
klanglos mit einem Beitritt zur
Sowjetunion im Status einer russischen
Teil Republik du warst Vereinnahmung
durch die Russen hat also grob geschätzt
30 Jahre gedauert ein anderes Beispiel
dies ist die Insel Sachalin sie ist so
groß wie Österreich über viele
Jahrhunderte wurde sie von China
beherrscht im 19 Jahrhundert begannen
jedoch Japan und Russland sich für die
Insel zu interessieren 1875 überliste
japanische Kaiser Hallen in einem
Vertrag seinem Petersburger Amtskollegen
allerdings ich hatte sich Japan dafür
die weiter östlich gelegene Inselkette
der kuririeren 1905 verloren Russland
einen Krieg gegen Japan und musste die
Südhälfte sachalins abtreten doch nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg holte sich die
Sowjetunion die Insel in ihrer
Gesamtheit zurück und die ganze
korrelienkette gleich noch mit dazu
etwas womit sich Japan bekanntlich bis
heute nicht abgefunden hat und so gibt
es noch eine ganze Reihe anderer Gebiete
an den heutigen Rändern Russlands die
man kaum den traditionellen russischen
Kernland zurechnen kann weiter im Osten
zum Beispiel des a-moll-gebiet und das
Küstengebiet mit wladibus Talk ein
riesiges Areal das Russland um 1860 dem
damals sehr schwachen China einfach
abgepresst hat und bis heute wird in den
nationalistischen Kreisen Chinas ganz
offen gefordert dass diese Demütigung
Chinas durch Russland rückgängig gemacht
werden muss
[Musik]
es wird ganz offen darüber debattiert
wie China den Osten der Russischen
Föderation wieder vereinnahmen könnte
aber das ist ein so gewaltiges Thema das
wir darüber bald ein eigenes sehr
interessantes Video herausbringen werden
also vergesst nicht das Abo und
aktiviert auch unbedingt das Glöckchen
um es nicht zu verpassen schwenken wir
nun aber als andere änderungslands dort
finden wir natürlich zum einen das
Gebiet Kaliningrad mit der einstigen
ostpreußischen Perle Königsberg
Kaliningrad ist heute als russische
Exklave zwischen den EU-Staaten Polen
und Litauen eingeklemmt über diese Stadt
die von den Russen zu einer gigantischen
Militärbasis im Herzen Europas ausgebaut
wurde haben wir übrigens schon eigenes
Video gedreht dass ich euch verlinken
werde östlich der heutigen Finish
russischen Grenze befindet sich ein Teil
Kareliens und Dieburg das vor dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg noch Finnlands
zweitgrößte Stadt gewesen war bei
Ausbruch des Zweiten Weltkriegs war die
russische nominierte Sowjetunion nämlich
eigentlich ein Verbündeter Hitlers erst
nachdem dieser seinem diktatorenkumpel
Stalin in den Rücken gefallen war
schwenkte sie für 4 Jahre zu einem Pakt
mit dem demokratischen Lager um von
diesem Waffen und Material in gewaltigem
Umfang zu erhalten zuvor hatten sich
aber eigentlich Hitler und Stalin Europa
in einem geheimen Zusatzprotokoll
aufgeteilt darin legten sie die
territorialpolitische Umgestaltung all
jener Staat mit Westies gemeinsam
überfallen und zerschlagen wollten Polen
sollte zwischen den Aggressoren
aufgeteilt werden Berlin Litauen
bekommen und unter die Herrschaft Moskau
sollte Estland Lettland Moldawien und
eben Finnland fallen gesagt getan 1939
fingen Hitler und Stalin mit der
Umsetzung ihres teuflischen Plans an das
war der Beginn des Zweiten Weltkriegs am
ersten September überfielen sie
gemeinsam Polen und im November wie die
Rote Armee in Finnland ein und obwohl
die Russen in diesem Winterkrieg
ordentlich auf den Park bekamen war
Helsinki ob seiner strategischen
Isolation gezwungen in einem
Friedensabkommen große Gebiete
abzutreten Gebiete die bis heute
russisch besetzt sind die Sowjet
vertrieben dabei aus Karelien und Borg
420.000 Menschen und zwar zusätzlich zu
einer etwa 150.000 literanischen
indischen Finnen aus der historischen
Region in German Land also dagegen um St
Petersburg 60.000 von ihnen wurden im
Rahmen einer magnetischen Säuberung aus
ihrer über Jahrhunderte angestammten
Heimat in sibirische Zwangsarbeitslager
deportiert was einem grausamen
Todesurteil gleich kam die finnische
Sprache wurde verboten jegliche
kulturellen Institutionen zerschlagen
und die meisten intellektuellen vor
allem lutheranische geistliche
exekutiert dieser ungesünnte Völkermord
an den Fingern wurde von Moskau aus
zentral geplant und gesteuert um die
gesamte Region gezielt zu
bolschevisieren und zu russifizieren
dabei wurden in erster Linie die
männliche Bevölkerung vernichtet denn
die russischen Kondensatoren
betrachteten die finnischen Bräute als
ihr Beutegut und ja diese perfide und
den höchsten Maße menschenverachtende
Kolonisierung spielte sich nicht
irgendwann im 17 Jahrhundert ab sondern
bis weit in den 1950er Jahre nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg verlangte Moskau sogar
die Auslieferung geflohener finden und
lockte sie mit dem Versprechen sich
wieder in ihren Heimatdorf ansiedeln zu
können und zwar nur um sie dann wieder
quer über das ganze Riesenreich zu
deportieren tja wie man sieht gehören
Völkermord und Kolonisierung leider zum
historischen standardreparatur der
russischen Politik und leider sind sie
bis heute tief in ihr verwurzelt denn
Russlands Expansion endete nicht mit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg ganz im Gegenteil im
Jahr 2014 annektierte Russland die Krim
und letztes Jahr annektierte es
zumindest auf dem Papier die beiden Don
Bass Provinzen sowie die Oblast des
saporicia und herson und ja wir sprechen
hier von waschechten Annexionen
schließlich hatte Russland selbst nach
dieser Falle so wird Union die Ukraine
mit ihren damaligen Grenzen als
souveränen Stadt anerkannt auf 9
russischen Karten sind nun also sowohl
die Creme als auch der Südosten der
Ukraine als Gebiete markiert die so
russisch sind die Sankt Petersburg oder
mit anderen Worten Russland verschiebt
auch heute noch seine Grenzen und zwar
ungeachtet jegliche internationale
Abkommen die es unterzeichnet hat
aber kommen wir zur zweiten konstante
der russischen Geschichte diese ist die
Unfähigkeit des Krems alle Teile seines
Territoriums angemessen mit Ressourcen
und öffentlichen Dienstleistungen zur
versorgen egal ob wir über das Imperium
des Zaren Sowjet Russland oder Putins
Reich sprechen Moskau versucht zwar
immer das ganze Land streng zu
kontrollieren aber gleichzeitig hapert
es mit der Förderung vieler provinsten
in denen nichts Nachhaltiges aufgebaut
wird zu Zaren Zeiten kumulierten sich
die Reichtümer des Imperiums in den
Petersburger zahnschlössern heute in den
Wolkenkratzern von Moskau City wir haben
das unglaublich asoziales System Putin
bereits im vorletzten Video anhand
seiner Eckdaten illustriert und 500
Superreiche Russen kontrollieren mehr
Vermögen als die Ärmsten 99,8 % der
Bevölkerung der unvorstellbar große
Diebstahl des russischen Volksvermögens
in die tascheneiniger weniger läuft auch
jetzt so geschmiert wie nie zuvor hatte
diese krasse Ausbeutung jedoch auch
vorher schon katastrophale strukturelle
Folgen werden diese jetzt im Krieg noch
härter ausfallen und noch mehr sozialen
regionalen und ethnischen Spannungen
führen und damit kommen wir zur dritten
konstante der russischen Geschichte der
Ambivalenz zwischen Zentralismus und
regionaler Selbstbestimmung das heißt in
manchen historischen Phasen hat Moskau
seine Regionen mehr autonomiezustandten
aber sie dann früher oder später doch
immer wieder einkassiert es ist ein
Spiel des hin und her Elmer Rahmen einer
bewährten teile und herrsche Strategie
wie sie auch Putin anzuwenden weiß ganz
anschaulich kann man dies momentan z.B
daran erkennen wie er die reguläre Armee
gegen Krieg gorgonzertruppe Wagner
ausspielt mal gewährt er der einen sein
Wohlwollen und Privilegien dann entzieht
er sie wieder und gönnt sie den anderen
nur um wenig später das ganze wieder
umzudrehen keiner soll wirklich wissen
woran er ist und sich gefälligst sputen
vor ein paar Wochen als bringt doch
schon ziemlich erkenntnislose Welle für
Welle in bachmund verheizte verbot er
ihm neue Häftlinge zu rekrutieren
drosselte auch die munitionslieferungen
für Wagner Verteidigungsminister
scheuburg hatte sich scheinbar gegen
seinen widersache durchgesetzt jetzt da
seine Arme jedoch noch schlechtere
Ergebnisse liefert dreht Putin in den
Munition den Hahn doch wieder auf wie
gesagt dieses Hin und Her hat in
Russland eine lange Tradition und wir
werden es sicher noch eine Weile
genießen dürfen so wie zum Beispiel auch
die 653 Verkündung der glorreichen
Eroberung des kleinen ostukrainischen
Städtchens Mahmut die pressfrage sowohl
im Kleinen als auch im großen lautet
also okay Russland versteht es
zweifellos Gebiete zu erobern aber kann
es sich auch auf Dauer halten oder
andersherum wie schnell könnte es sie
wieder verlieren nun genau das werden
wir uns jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
unabhängige Staaten innerhalb Russlands
wir haben es schon vorhin erwähnt etwa
ein Viertel der Region Russlands nennt
sich Republik und dann wird zumeist der
Name eines dort lebenden Volkes Republik
Karelien zum Beispiel klingt eigentlich
genauso stolz wie die Eigenbezeichnung
Frankreichs la Republik Frances all
diese russischen Republiken hatten den
Sowjet Zeiten den offiziellen Status
einer ass-r also eine autonomen
sozialistischen Sowjetrepublik Worte die
autonomen und Republik klingen sehr nach
Souveränität Abhängigkeit und eigenem
Staatswesen und das sollten sie
eigentlich auch ja der Punkt ist nur
diese Territorien waren immer
Bestandteil der Sowjetunion heute eben
aus Russlands aber wie kann man
gleichzeitig irgendwie unabhängig und
auch Teil eines Landes sein nun an
dieser Stelle kommt hierher ins Spiel
die ihr jetzt auf den Bildschirm seht
wir sprechen von Josip sogar Willi
genannt Stalin ja genau der mit den
Gulags und Deportation als die
Kommunisten unterdessen Vorgänger Linien
an die Macht gekommen waren standen sie
schnell vor dem Problem dass es ethnisch
gesehen zwei große Gruppen von
vorwerk-bürgern gab nämlich zum einen
die Russen und zum anderen die nicht
Russen schließlich hatten die Zaren ihre
Territorium seit Jahrhunderten immer
weiter ausgedehnt manchmal in einem
Tempo das einem Belgien pro Jahr
entsprach okay ich weiß dass ein Belgien
keine standardisierte Maßeinheit ist
aber es verdeutlicht doch das sehr viele
nicht russische Völker unter die
Zarenherrschaft geraten waren und wenn
deren Lebensraum anfangs noch an der
Peripherie des Reiches lag zurückden sie
mit dem Fortschreiten dieser Expansion
immer weiter ins Landesinnere so gesehen
handelt es sich auch um eine Art von
Integration ihr erinnert euch noch an
dieses ich euch vorhin auf der Karte
gezeigt habe nun bei den echten
Randgebieten irgendwo in Ostsibirien
bestand die Beziehung zum Zarenhof lange
Zeit nur darin dass dorthin Tribut zu
entrichten war ansonsten bewachten diese
Gebiete ihre eigene Kultur ihre Religion
und ihre Sprache und denkt jetzt nicht
dass wir über kleine Gebiete sprechen
ganz im Gegenteil dieses hier ist zum
Beispiel die Republik sagt
Sacher ist so groß wie ganz Indien und
damit die größte Teilregion Russlands
Sacher ist auch der Eigenname des dort
heimischen Volkes das wir so wie die
Russen auch yakuten nennen oder hier zum
Beispiel am Baikalsee die Republik
buriatien sie ist so groß wie
Deutschland die borriaten sind ein
buddhistisches Volk ihre Sprache ist mit
dem mongolischen verwandt allerdings
stellen die Burjaten heute nur etwa 30 %
der Bevölkerung pro Jahr ziehen 60 %
sind Russen in yakuzien also der
Republik Sacher stellen die akuten mit
55%, aber immerhin noch knapp einem
Mehrheit und nachdem ich euch über die
rossifizierung der ehemals finnischen
Regionen erzählt habe könnt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich schon denken wie es auch
hier dazu gekommen ist aber trotzdem
liegen uns talien waren sich einig dass
der beste Weg um all diese völkerung
Gebiete in ihr neues kommunistisch
Utopia einzugehen darin bestand Ihnen
einen offiziellen Sonderstatus zu geben
dieser Region sollten also zumindest auf
dem Papier ihre eigene Sprache ihre
eigene Kultur und ihre eigenen Tradition
behalten und pflegen können man nannte
dass die Politik der Verwurzelung
allerdings wurden schon sehr heißt die
Daumenschrauben angezogen zuerst bei der
Religion denn wahre Kommunisten
bezeichnen Religion ja als Opium fürs
Volk und andere bezeichnen dafür den
Kommunismus als Religion ohne einen
überirdischen Gott aber wie dem auch sei
auf jeden Fall wurden auf diese Weise
die autonomen Republiken Russlands
geboren also das heißt diese Regionen
hat Russland hatten zwar eine eigene
Verfassung sie konnten ihre Sprache und
Kultur behalten aber es souverän waren
sie nicht und jetzt ist besondere
Vorsicht geboten wenn wir dürfen diese
autonomen Republiken auch nicht mit den
sozialistischen Sowjet Republiken
verwechseln die Ukraine und Kasachstan
zum Beispiel waren solche Teilstaaten
der Ende 1922 ausgerufen und so wird
Union der UdSSR in der Union der
Sozialistischen Sowjet Republiken Formel
waren sie so wäre eine Staaten die laut
Verfassung sogar das Recht hatten aus
der Sowjetunion auszutreten doch wie
gesagt besonders lange hielt dieser gute
Wille den vielen Völkerschaften im
Rahmen des Sowjetsystems ihre eigenen
nationale Identität zu garantieren nicht
an nach etwas mehr mehr als nur einem
Jahrzehntes bewiesenen guten Willens
wurde in den aus einem 30er Jahren die
faktische Autonomie wieder
zurückgefahren Stalin führte russisch
wieder als Pflichtsprache an den Schulen
ein Theater und Kulturinstitutionen der
titularnation bekam Schwierigkeiten und
wurden auf vielfältige Weise schikaniert
es begann der Terror mit Deportation und
kultureller Gleichschaltung
vielerortsübernahmen wieder Russen das
Kommando das war unsere Regel Nummer
drei die regionale Selbstbestimmung darf
nicht zu stark werden auf dem Papier
wurde das Konzept der autonomen
Republiken Inhalt Russland jedoch
beibehalten und das ist sehr wichtig
warum nun passt jetzt gut auf
als Russland fast auseinander gebrochen
wäre
[Musik]
die Sowjetunion Ende der 80er Beginn der
90er Jahre das ganze Land steht am Rande
des Zusammenbruchs und das Ergebnis jede
Menge Territorien die sich vom Joch
moskauslösen wollen und sich fürs
souverän erklären es begann ein ziemlich
chaotischer Prozess den man als Parade
des Souveränitäten betitelte um die
totale des Integration der udss zu
vermeiden er liest der damalige Sowjet
Führer Michael Gorbatschow am 26 April
1990 ein Gesetz das den 15
übergeordneten sowie Republiken faktisch
volle staatliches Souveränität zu
belegte nehmt Euch so viel Realität wie
ihr vertragen könnt sponte auch bares
Geld sie in der neue Präsident der
russischen Kerner Republik seinen
Nachbarn noch an das galt allerdings
nicht für die autonomen Republiken
innerhalb Russlands was diese jedoch
nicht hinter sich trotzdem einseitig
auch für souverän oder gar unabhängig zu
erklären und sich selbst den Status
einer Republik innerhalb des probiert
Union zu sprechen selbst manche
russische Oblast erklärte sich damals
zum selbstbestimmten Subjekt von Moskau
wurde dies natürlich nie anerkannt aber
man hatte dort auch ganz andere Probleme
als
Selbstherrlichkeit regionaler Fürsten
für bare Münze zu nehmen es war damals
offensichtlich dass ich so wird Union in
ihrer bisherigen Formel nicht erhalten
werden kann und viele Regionen
versuchten einfach vor dem Einstieg in
eine der heiß diskutierten
nachfolgelösungen einen maximal hohen
Status an Selbstständigkeit zu erreichen
bei den souveränitätsbestrebungen
handelt es sich oft also um eine
Verhandlungsmasse trotzdem das
Durcheinander war gewaltig und dann kam
im August 1991 auch noch der
gescheiterte Putsch gegen Gotthard der
die Zentrifugalkräfte mächtig verstärkte
in der Folge sehr viel die Sowjetunion
Ende 91 in jene 15 Staaten von Estland
bis Tadschikistan die wir auch heute auf
der Landkarte sehen und das alles hat
der Rest der Welt auch sehr schnell so
anerkannt aber was geschah damals
eigentlich innerhalb Russlands nun in
vielen der selbstbewusst gewordenen
stellte man sich die Frage sind wir
jetzt eigentlich noch keine Russlands
oder doch nicht denn wenn die Ukraine
von Moskau unabhängig geworden sind
warum können das nicht auch wirklich
Schäden oder Tataren schließlich handelt
es sich bei den Unterschieden in unserem
nationalen Status nur um eine
Formalitäten in Tschetschenien hatte man
deswegen schon im Sommer 1991 kurze hat
die Republik ich kehre ja als
unabhängige Stadt ausgerufen
doch auch in patastern also sozusagen
mitten in Russland wurde im März 92 eine
Volksabstimmung abgehalten die Frage
lautete sind Sie damit einverstanden
dass die Republik vertaristan 1 zu
Verena Staat und ein Subjekt des
internationalen Beziehungen zu
Russischen Föderation und anderen
Republiken und unabhängigen Staaten auch
der Basis gleichberechtigter Verträge
eingeht nun bei sage und schreibe 82%
Wahlbeteiligung stimmten 61% mit ja und
das interpretierte man als deutliche
Mehrheit für eine vollwertige staatliche
Unabhängigkeit
interessant dabei ist das offenbar auch
nicht wenige ethnische Russen für die
Unabhängigkeit rotierten denn der
Bevölkerungsanteil der Tataren lag
damals unter 50 Prozent und das weiß
nicht etwa deswegen der Fall weil man
sich so ähnlich wäre die Tataren sind
eine völlig andere Ethnie als die Russen
bei ersteren handelt es sich
mehrheitlich um Muslime und sie sprechen
eine Durchsprache allerdings haben sich
bei der Volksgruppen im Laufe von 400
Jahren russischer Herrschaft auch
partiell vermischt aber wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt stellten damals in
Kreml alle Alarmglocken einem weiteren
nur jetzt die direkt an der Wolga
zwingen uns diese Tataren jetzt etwa
auch unsere Armee dorthin zu schicken um
sie niederzuletzeln nun glücklicherweise
waren die Tataren keine Hitzköpfe
sondern Realisten deshalb gelang ist
jetzt in die Tataren zum Bleiben zu
überreden und wie nun mit gutmütlichkeit
zugeschnitten und langen Verhandlungen
in den 90er Jahren handelte der Kreml
dann mit jeder einzelnen Republik einen
bilateralen Vertrag aus das erklärt
warum jede Teile Republik mehr oder
weniger Autonomie hatte je nachdem wie
gut sie eben mit ein bisschen gepokert
hatte im Falle tatas Tanz hatte Moskau
keine andere Wahl als 94 in einem
Vertrag mehr Autonomie als allen anderen
Regionen zu gewähren das erklärt warum
die Tataren über Jahre hinweg in der
Lage waren eigene Steuern zu erheben
ihre Bodenschätze selbst zu verwalten
ihren Bürgern eine Art
Staatsbürgerschaft zu gewähren und sich
sogar in gewissen Dingen eine eigene
Außenpolitik erlauben konnten und dies
meine Lieben Zuschauer machte einen
riesen Unterschied denn mit der Zeit
zeigte sich dass die Republik tatastran
eine viel bessere Infrastruktur
entwickeln konnte und auch viel stärker
industrialisiert ist als ihre Nachbarn
mit anderen Worten rübergehen schien es
als hätte jeder eine Lösung für die
Integration aller Ethnien in seiner
neuen russischen Föderation gefunden
okay es handelte sich trotzdem um einen
Föderalismus ungleiches Objekt aber
immerhin irgendwie hat das alles
funktioniert das Problem dabei nun
erinnert ihr euch an Russlands drittes
eisernes Gesetz bei regionaler
Selbstbestimmung darf es sich nur um
eine flüchtige und vorübergehende
Erscheinung handeln und der gute Wille
hielt so lange an bis mit Beginn des
Jahres
ein neuer Pächter im Kreml Einzug
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Putin und die Rückkehr zum Zentralismus
wisst ihr eigentlich wie die politische
Partei Wladimir Putins heißt ganz genau
Einiges Russland glaubt mir dieser Name
ist kein Zufall sondern Programm denn
wenn es etwas gibt das Putin nicht mag
dann ist es dieser Gutmenschen
Föderalismus
[Musik]
2004 schaffte Putin die demokratische
Direktwahl der regional Gouverneure ab
im Jahr 2013 hat er sie zwar wieder
eingeführt aber mit vielen Klauseln und
vorbehalten kurz um die regional
kombinare werden faktisch von Moskau
vorbestimmt zwischen 2012 und 2018 hat
Moskau auf diese Weise sage und schreibe
63 Gouverneure ausgetauscht
statt selbstbewusster Regionalfürsten
wie früher sind sie nun jederzeit
ablösbare Kreml Statthalter und
verschämt hat auch eine Republik nach
der anderen aus ihren Verfassungen den
Passus aus den 90er Jahren sie sein
eigentlich souveräne starten gestrichen
ja das gilt auch für die vergleichsweise
starke Autonomie katastrams 2007 wurde
der Vertrag über die gegenseitige
Abgrenzung der Vollmachten nochmal
verlängert aber 2017 liest der Kreml ihn
einfach auslaufen nun war also Schluss
mit lustig katastran war nun
gleichgeschaltet Putins scheibchenweise
Salami Taktik hin zum Totalitarismus ist
auch in diesem Punkt aufgegangen die
letzten Relikte an Sonderrechten musste
das Parlament in der Hauptstadt Kasan
erst vor kurzem aus der Republik
Verfassung streichen keine Souveränität
mehr keine eigene Staatsbürgerschaft und
kein eigenes Verfassungsgericht mehr und
Tata tanzt langjähriger Präsident
Russland auf darf sich der PayPal 2023
auch nicht mehr Präsident nennen sondern
nur noch Reis ist zu deutsch Oberhaupt
denn eine Russland darf es ab jetzt nur
noch einen Präsidenten geben ihr wisst
schon Lena mit anderen Worten man kann
heute mit Fug und Recht sagen dass
Russland nur noch dem Namen nach einer
Föderation ist alle wesentlichen
Entscheidungen werden in Moskau
getroffen die Region haben nichts mehr
zu melden und das macht sich vor allem
beim Geld bemerkbar zwischen 2012 und
2018 sind die Steuereinnahmen des
gremmels in Rubel um 77% gestiegen die
der Region dagegen nur um drei Prozent
was bedeutet das also nun die
Bestätigung von Regel Nummer 3 wir geben
euch etwas Souveränität und Autonomie um
euch bei der Stange zu halten solange
die Lage für uns schwierig ist aber ein
paar Jahre später sobald wir wieder
Oberwasser genommen haben nehmen wir
euch alles wieder weg wobei sich viele
von euch jetzt vielleicht denken gut das
macht doch eigentlich Sinn ein Land mit
so vielen territorial Ungleichheiten
braucht eine Umverteilung der Ressourcen
zum Beispiel werden 80% des Haushalts
aus dem föderalen Topf überwiesen aber
unverteilung ist schon gut wenn sie denn
richtig funktioniert denn im Falle
Russland produziert und provoziert der
Zentralismus auch große Probleme und
welche genau werden wir uns jetzt
ansehen also aufgepasst
die guten ins Körbchen der Rest in den
Fleischwolf
in Russland gibt es über den Republiken
und Gebieten noch eine andere Stative
Untergliederung die sogenannten
föderationskreise davon gibt es acht
Stück ihrer Vollmachten sind nicht der
Rede wert aber für die Statistik liefern
sie durchaus gutes Vergleichsmaterial
schauen wir uns doch mal den territorial
größten föderationskreis an den fernen
Osten der fernostbezirk Macht 41% des
russischen Territoriums aus hat aber die
geringste Einwohnerzahl aller acht
Kreise nur 5,5% der russischen
Bevölkerung leben dort denn keine Frage
das Klima da hinten ist ziemlich hart
und wenig menschenfreundlich und
vielleicht habt ihr ja auch schon davon
gehört dass der Kältepol der Erde in
Jakutien liegt ein anderer fakt ist aber
auch im Süden dieses Gebiets entlang der
chinesischen Grenze oder im Umland von
Stock herrschen ziemlich humane Klima
Bedingungen zumindest ist das Klima so
gut dass dort jede Menge so ja und Reise
wächst und dennoch verlieren sich hier
nicht einmal 8 Millionen Menschen und
das auf einem Gebiet so groß wie Indien
und Argentinien zusammengenommen gleich
neben einem China leben allein in den
und innerer Mongolei 57 Millionen und
für chinesische Verhältnisse sind sie
dünn besiedelt aber Russlands Probleme
mit dem fernen Osten sind Stoff für ein
ganz eigenes Video dessen wir uns bald
annehmen werden denn diese Probleme
dürften noch eine entscheidende Rolle
für das Gelingen oder Scheitern von
Putin Strategie des Schwenks nach Osten
werden und vielleicht fragt ihr euch
jetzt warum leben dort eigentlich nur so
wenige Menschen nun in erster Linie weil
es dort kaum Arbeit gibt und warum das
wiederum nun weil über Jahrzehnte sehr
wenig in die Infrastruktur und sonstige
Investitionen floss
das Verkehrsnetz von russisch Fernost
besteht im Prinzip nur aus zwei
Bahnlinien der Transit und der nördlich
parallel verlaufenden BAM ja und es gibt
eine Straße ja genau eine die dieses
riesige Gebiet mit dem Rest des Landes
verbindet selbst ja kurz die Hauptstadt
der riesigen Republik Sacha ist auf dem
Landweg nicht zu erreichen Straße wie
Bahnlinie Enden auf der anderen Seite
der Lena einem riesigen sibirischen
Strom aber klar im Winter fährt man mit
dem Auto einfach rüber über das Eis um
euch eine Vorstellung von dem riesigen
Investitionsstau zu geben schon in den
1980er Jahren begann man hier eine
ganzjährig nutzbare Brücke zu planen
unter Putin wurde das Projekt dann
langsam konkret und dann 2014 auf Eis
gelegt zu werden ja wortwörtlich auf Eis
und warum nun weiß ich in diesem Jahr
Russland die Halbinsel Grimm einverleibt
hatte damit wurde für den Krimi die
Entwicklung dieses neuen Territoriums
Priorität und das für die drei Kilometer
lange Brücke in yakuzien schon
reservierte Geld Fluss in das ähnlich
große Projekt der Brücke von Kerstin nun
die Krim großland verwendet denn wenn
der Kreml etwas beschließt dann wird das
eben durchgezogen kostet es was es wolle
ein Beispiel die Olympischen
Winterspiele 2014 in Putins Lieblings
Ferienort Sotschi waren die bis dato
teuersten der Geschichte aber klar das
Geld muss dann eben woanders eingespart
werden so kommt es dass man in yakuzien
schon seit Jahrzehnten auf eine Brücke
über die Lena wartet obwohl sie der
Entwicklung der an Bodenschätzen reichen
Region sicher einen mächtigen Schub
geben würde aber warum sollten die
Herren aus Moskau denn auch das Geld
dass sie mit dem Rohstoffexport
verdienen wieder in die Region
zurückfließen lassen aus denen sie
stammen und so kommt es dass 20% der
russischen Bevölkerung zu Hause immer
noch kein fließendes Wasser haben die
Perspektiven nun bei kurz werden
gegenwärtig ein paar hochspannungsmasken
versetzt um Platz für den Bau der Brücke
zu machen man hofft dass die
Finanzierung nun irgendwie im zweiten
Anlauf doch noch klappt klar mitten im
Krieg und unterschweren Sanktionen aber
vor allem hat man mal wieder die
Rechnung ohne die Kreml gemacht der die
zentrale hat eben fast unbegrenzte Macht
über die Haushaltsmittel und gerade
jetzt hat Putin eben ganz andere
Prioritäten die absoluten Vorrang vor
der Entwicklung entlegener Provinzen
haben einerseits muss er wegen des
Ukraine Krieg seine Militärausgaben
erhöhen andererseits muss er die durch
den Krieg und Krise gestressten
Staatsfinanzen halbwegs beieinander
halten viele Regionen werden wohl wieder
ins Abseits geschoben oder haben das
Nachsehen aber wir reden hier nicht nur
über Geld wir reden auch über
Menschenleben was glaubt ihr woher die
meisten in der Ukraine gefallenen
russischen Soldaten kommen nun seht euch
mal diese Grafik an die sicher nur eine
Annäherung an die realen Zahlen ist aber
sie gibt uns eine Vorstellung davon wie
hier die Dinge laufen
[Musik]
es handelt sich um die durch
Publikationen bestätigten Todesfälle
russischer Militärangehörige in der
Ukraine insgesamt etwa 20.000 zum
Zeitpunkt Erstellung dieses Videos haben
120 aus der Regionen Moskau stammende
Soldaten ihr Leben verloren wenn wir
bedenken das Moskau 13 Millionen
Einwohner hat kann man sagen dass die
meisten moskau-familien wohl keine
schlaflosen Nächte zu brauchen haben tja
was ist aber mit anderen Regionen wie
etwa der Republik pro Jahr ziehen hier
sehen wir eine Zahl von 632 gefallen
nennen das heißt einer von 1500
Einwohnern ist definitiv schon im Krieg
gefallen mit anderen Worten es gibt
immer mehr Menschen in diesen Regionen
deren Verwandte oder Bekannte in diesem
Krieg getötet wurden wohlgemerkt in
einem Krieg der tausende von Kilometer
entfernt stattfindet und nebenbei
bemerkt es bringt Tuba offenbar gar
nichts das Verteidigungsminister Scholl
selbst aus dem kleinen Volk der TU
Wiener stammt er schont seine eigenen
Landsleute kein bisschen doch was
bedeutet das alles eigentlich für den
weiteren Zusammenhalt der Russischen
Föderation nun wir haben von einer
vertrauenswürdigen Quelle aus einer
anderen kleinen sibirischen Republik
erfahren dass dort die Kriegslust
ziemlich hoch ist angefeuert von der
massiven fernsehpropaganda des
russischen Staates und schlimmer noch
viele Männer des dortigen Volkes wollen
jetzt erst recht in den Krieg ziehen um
sich an den Ukrainern zu rächen die
schon so viele ihrer Landsleute
umgebracht haben tja da kann man
wirklich nur sagen Diagnose Gehirnwäsche
erfolgreich verlaufen dazu muss man
allerdings auch wissen dass es dort
außer einer Laufbahn bei der Armee für
viele kaum eine berufliche Perspektive
gibt so weit so schlecht also
andererseits gibt es angesichts von
Putin in der Ukraine verursachte das
auch neue autonomiebewegungen viele
Menschen dort haben den Eindruck dass
Russland als historisch überkommen ist
imperialistisches Großreich in den
letzten Zügen liegt und der Ukraine
Krieg sozusagen ein letztes Aufbäumen in
der Agonie vor dem unweigerlichen
Zerfall darstellt schließlich haben sich
auch andere überdehnte viel Völker
reiche mit unter relativ schnell
aufgelöst vom römischen Reich über das
Inkareich in Südamerika bis zum
britischen Empire bietet uns die
Geschichte da reichlich interessante
Beispiele auf jeden Fall wurde im Jahr
2022 ein Forum der freien Nationen
Russlands gegründet in dem sich mehrere
separatistische Bewegungen zu
organisieren beginnen und über die
Möglichkeit als Tschetschenien unter der
Führung des vermeintlich treuen
putinvasalen ramsam kardi rauf nur auf
einen günstigen Moment wartet um sich
erneut in die Unabhängigkeit zu
verabschieden tja darüber haben wir erst
unlängst ein Video gedreht den Link
findet ihr wie immer in der Beschreibung
und selbst in der ehemaligen Hauptstadt
Sankt Petersburg Termin manche insgeheim
von einer freien nähbare Republik eine
unabhängigen Region in German Land oder
gar von einem Revival der vorbildhaft
basisdemokratischen Republik groß noch
gehort aus dem Mittelalter auch dieser
haben leider vor über 500 Jahren die
moskovita in ihrem notorischen
explosionsdrang denn da ausgemacht aber
meine Lieben Politik Zuschauer was heißt
das werden wir wirklich eine
separatistische Bewegung in Russland
erleben eine neue Parade des zuverengtät
wie vor gut 30 Jahren nun das weiß im
Moment noch niemand das Potenzial ist
vorhanden aber es ist noch zu früh um
dies definitiv vorherzusagen es könnte
durchaus noch viele Jahre dauern bis bei
den Menschen in den Provinzen von
großputinstern die Erkenntnis reift
welche finsteres Spiel der Kreml und
dessen aktueller allein Herrscher mit
ihnen Arno 2022 und 23 gespielt haben
hier auf visualpolitik können wir die
Zukunft auch nicht vorhersagen aber wir
können sagen dass die strukturellen
Probleme des zaristischen Russlands oder
so wird Union auch in Putins Russland
fortbestehen und so wie Russland in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder mit
ethnischen Spannungen und territorialen
Zerreißproben zu kämpfen hatte könnte in
dies in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft auch
wieder passieren dabei gab es in diesem
Video eine Menge Aspekte zu diesem
Themen Kreis die wir nur oberflächlich
gestreift haben oder aus Zeitgründen
ganz auslassen mussten aber keine Angst
der werden in kommenden Videos wieder in
sie eintauchen vor allem was China
angeht also Abo nicht vergessen
allerdings soll uns das jetzt nicht
hindern die Diskussion zu öffnen was
meint ihr werden wir in Russland eine
neue Welle separatistischer Bewegungen
erleben wird Russland in der Lage sein
eine andere neue Lösung für all diese
Republiken und Ethnien zu finden könnte
das Land und oder seine Regime
schlichtweg auseinanderfallen wenn es
sich in der Ukraine eine schallende
Niederlage einfängt was würde im Falle
einer solchen Balkanisierung mit dem
russischen Atomwaffenarsenal
basierendsten Händel würde es fallen und
könnte es da nicht auch passieren dass
robust aufgestellte Nachbarstaaten wie
Polen Finnland China oder Japan eine
solche Situation ausnutzen um alte
territoriale Rechnungen mit Russland zu
begleichen wir werden all das sicher in
zukünftigen Videos behandeln aber wie
immer sind wir jetzt auf eure Diskussion
gespannt ich hoffe auch dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat mir vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns
bitte ein Like und teilt es mit euren
Freunden um es mit ihnen ausgiebig zu
diskutieren natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hat dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung den Video macht's gut und
bis bald
[Musik]